where he helps implement the president's
domestic climate agenda coordinating the
all of government approach to tackle the
climate crisis creating good paying
union jobs and advance environmental
justice ali was formally at stanford's
pre-court institute for energy where he
taught graduate students in stem on
economic and technology policy topics
related to climate change for eight
years zadie served in key roles within
the obama biden administration including
as the associate director for natural
resources energy and science at omb as
deputy director of energy policy for the
domestic policy council and as a senior
director for cabinet affairs he is here
today to discuss the biden harris lead
pipe and paint action plan which was
announced earlier today i hope you all
join me in welcoming him welcoming him
to the uh to the podium into the
briefing rooms his first time so all
yours he's going to take probably like
two or three questions afterwards i'll
let you know who gets called on but
thank you so much
podium is yours
thank you corrine
uh and good to be with everybody
here today
um
president biden and vice president
harris believe that no child no family
no american should have to worry about
lead exposure from the water that they
drink or the air that they breed that's
why today we're announcing the biden
harris lead pipe and paint action plan
10 agencies stepping forward with 15
bold actions the nation's largest
investment in infrastructure to take on
and tackle this public health crisis and
this staggering source of environmental
injustice
let's do some of the numbers here lead
exposure threatens
millions of americans through their
water up to 10 million households and
400 000 schools and child care centers
through lead paint in nearly 24 million
housing units this is where people live
and we know that these exposures are
highly unsafe
especially for our kids
we're not just finding out we've known
this for over 100 years in fact congress
passed a law banning new lead pipes in
the year i was born
and in the years since we've let these
pipes persist in our communities
and the truth is they persisted the
longest in low-income communities
whether rural or urban and in
communities
of color
the good news is this we know how to get
after this challenge and fix this
problem and that's why president biden
and vice president harris have made
replacing lead pipes a centerpiece of
the bipartisan infrastructure law
and why today
vice president harris stood with child
health champions and labor union leaders
alike to join together and issue this
action plan with a new goal to make
rapid progress replacing all lead pipes
in this decade
working in close collaboration with our
state local and tribal partners with a
focus on communities that have been
underserved and overburdened and in a
way that creates good paying jobs jobs
welding and fabricating jobs fitting and
installing these upgrades jobs in
infrastructure that can support a family
today's action plan has three pillars
the first is about getting resources
into the hands of communities epa is
announcing that nearly 3 billion
from the bipartisan infrastructure law
will be deployed deployed next year in
2022 to replace these pipes and we're
going to tap into the american rescue
plan that the president passed at the
beginning of his administration with its
350 billion dollars in state local and
tribal recovery funds
second
the epa is writing new regulations that
will strengthen the lead and copper rule
include including enhanced testing
requirements this is absolutely critical
that we pair the investments with clear
standards about where we need to go and
third we're marshaling tools from across
our agencies 10 of them bringing actions
to the table so that we can tackle this
crisis head on and just as an example
we've got a cabinet-level partnership a
bunch of agencies coming together at the
very top of the agencies
focused on lead remediation in schools
and child care centers we've got the cdc
working overtime to make sure we close
those gaps that we have in critical
health screening
across our federal housing portfolio
hud usda the department of interior we
are working to eliminate lead pipes and
lead paint hazards
and we've got epa and the department of
labor working with local communities not
only to accelerate projects but make
sure that we do them in partnership with
unions
thanks to the leadership of the
president and the vice president we
passed a big deal bipartisan
infrastructure law
and that's going to help us replace all
the lead pipes and we're excited to get
to work with that your take some
questions
thank you so much ollie
i'd like to ask you about the buildback
better plan the
plan is sort of clearly at risk right
now in congress certainly not doesn't
look like it's going to happen before
christmas
the climate piece is a good chunk of
that what will you guys do in your
office
if those provisions don't end up getting
passed and how does the president then
attempt to
proceed with his goals of of reducing
emissions without it jeff thanks for for
the question um
you know what we're talking about today
i think reinforces the case for
investing in america
every dollar that we invest in this
challenge to take on the lead pipe
crisis around the country yields three
dollars of benefits it's going to unlock
a good jobs it's going to unlock public
health benefits it's going to help
revitalize communities left out and left
behind and the buildback better act does
exactly that same thing a playbook that
is focused on
boosting our economic resilience and
taking on the climate crisis and we're
excited to be involved in conversations
that help us move forward but let me
also note this
from day one in this administration
every single day the president has been
advancing critical climate action you
look at some of the actions we've taken
in just the last few months
tackling super pollutants in the form of
hydrocarbons tackling methane emissions
not only here but bringing around uh
over a hundred countries from around the
world to take on the same challenge
making sure we're shifting quickly to an
electric vehicle future so we're excited
to be continuing to push forward in an
ambitious way in a bold way and i think
today's announcement really brings home
the point if we invest in america we
create good paying jobs we unlock
environmental benefits all at the same
time
what are your biggest concerns about
things that may be taken out of that
bill if it passes at all in the climate
space
you know again want to focus on what
we're doing today because uh as i noted
um you know this is action that is long
overdue i think the american people are
excited uh to see us get to work in
taking on something that's festered in
communities for over a hundred years um
but we're look we're leaning in to every
opportunity we've got the president's
been very clear when he sees the climate
crisis he sees the motivation to move
with the urgency and pace that's
necessary at the scale that's necessary
and he sees jobs
and we're excited to be bringing those
jobs into communities helping sustain
families all around the country
ali thank you for being here the
president had said he wanted 45 billion
dollars to deal with lead pipes and to
deal with issue this issue in the
infrastructure bill obviously he got
closer to 15 billion dollars you guys
say that's still enough to deal with it
100 how is that the case if you didn't
get if you only got a third of the money
you were looking for absolutely thank
you for raising that question um
one of the things that's been remarkable
uh and
i think this is the case on lead pipes i
think there's a case on a lot of things
you look at electric vehicles for
example uh in in just this last year and
it's accelerated since folks got
together on the south lawn in august
we've had the detroit three invest
almost 100 billion dollars into the
electric vehicle future um the strength
of this president's leadership the
certainty and clarity with which he has
project projected the vision i think is
bringing uh folks to the table with
resources and creativity and one example
of that creativity is american rescue
plan which included 350 billion dollars
to support state and local governments
we've got folks in milwaukee who now
have six million dollars from that arp
funding that's supporting job training
to help replace lead pipes we've got
folks in duluth minnesota 11 million
dollars from that american rescue plan
going towards lead remediation i grew up
in erie pennsylvania so i'm particularly
excited about the six and a half million
bucks that governor wolf helped unlock
so that erie can get after
some of the lead gooseneck
issues that they've got in the community
so one we are seeing folks sprinting in
this direction right now right away the
second thing and this is where the
action plan comes in is we've been
working really hard to make sure that
we're being inventive and creative in
the way we go after this challenge that
means creating regional technical
assistance hubs it means making sure
that we're standardizing contracting
we're using the best technology we're
using data tools to help bend the cost
curve because this doesn't have to cost
as much as it's always costed we have
been learning along the way and it's
time to harness those learnings to
deliver the solutions that the american
people are looking for april
um punching the numbers a little bit
more drilling down a little bit more
when you talk about different areas a
lot of it's a heavy lift when it comes
to piping and infrastructure and going
into houses going into the streets and
then you have
the paint in homes that's easier to
remediate
over these 10 years can you give us the
numbers the anticipation of numbers that
we're going to see when it comes to the
remediation pipes lead pipes as well as
pain
give us the stats
yeah absolutely um we know today uh we
estimate that there are six to ten
million homes that are impacted by lead
service lines and we need to do
everything that we can to move as
quickly through that challenge as
possible
but we also recognize and i think it's
important to be transparent about this
that
a little bit of this is mapping the
topography of the mountain as we're
starting to climb it
we have to go out there we have to
collect the data there are communities
around the united states where we don't
know where the pipes are so those are
estimates we need to figure that out on
the front end that's why we're investing
in the data and the community engagement
to figure that out but the goal is very
clear uh within this decade making sure
we're getting after that challenge and
on the lead paint uh front that is a
place where we need to continue to
accelerate marshall investment it's
something where the buildback better
plan actually does invest dollars and
we're using the resources we have
already available to us talked about hud
usda and also
the department of the interior which
works in indian country uh making sure
that we're making those resources
available
but as you talk about climbing the
mountain do you still at least have a
baseline of what you want to see
accomplished over this decade
yeah the baseline is this we've got 15
billion dollars of funding in the
bipartisan infrastructure law we're
going to move three billion of that next
year we're going to leverage that uh
significantly we're going to mobilize
the resources we're already mobilizing
through the american rescue plan that
are creating jobs right now and
improving quality of life and health
conditions in communities like duluth
like milwaukee like back home in erie
pennsylvania we're excited about that
work
just real quick ally thanks for being
here you say 3 billion of the 15 billion
will be
sent out next year
do you yet know
when
precisely approximately the first lead
pipe will actually be removed from the
building and replaced with a new one
we are seeing ed thank you for the
question uh and i remember you from your
uh federal eye days so good to see you
um
it it is
throwback uh
it is so uh important that we start
making this progress right away
and you look at for example the city of
pittsburgh which now has a plan to get
all the pipes out
by 2026
the the funds from the american rescue
plan already mobilized uh and taking
pipes out of the ground replacing them
with a safer alternative um these
dollars will accelerate that effort and
uh i don't think we're skipping a beat
here what we've been doing as an
administration is building the
relationships and building
to use a maybe tried term
the infrastructure to deliver
the resources that we need make sure it
gets metabolized in the system as
quickly as possible so i think that the
short answer your question is it's
already making a difference in
communities right now and we're really
excited about that
thank you for being here could you
address environmentalists their concerns
about the plan
uh just setting a goal for removing the
lead service lines versus mandating that
these lines be removed can you explain
why the administration has gone
that way and not
absolutely i'm really i i
as a as an environmentalist uh
appreciate you asking that question um
this is a multi-prong approach and
setting the goal is the motivation and
and i think uh the point hopefully i've
conveyed is
simply by setting that goal uh president
biden vice president harris have
motivated action in communities all
around the country already but that's
not enough and what the epa is doing is
embarking on rulemaking that will create
new binding requirements
uh so that we can have the certainty i
mean you just think about you put your
kid in the car you don't just buckle
them up with a regular seat belt you put
them in the car seat you put the seat
belt on
i would say a lot of my friends click
four or five things before they start
driving
we're going to invest we're going to set
standards we're going to bring technical
assistance we're going to be there
shoulder to shoulder with folks as they
take on this challenge
and the epa is doing that and and just
to speak to the epa process on day one
the first day of this administration the
president signed an order uh
reestablishing the scientific integrity
of our rulemaking processes and so that
is what's going to dictate the process
but the goals are very clear and i think
you heard them from michael regan
our administrator
how vigorously uh the epa intends to
develop
standards requirements uh to make sure
that we're delivering on the target okay
we're gonna take two more phil and zolan
hello
follow my good friend jeff's lead and
broaden it out a little bit if you don't
mind given the scale of the
administration's climate ambitions of
which this is very much a good example
of have you guys felt any constraints on
the regulatory side
by concern over
securing one vote in particular in the
united states senate in terms of what
you're able to do how far you're able to
go uh in terms of your agenda on the
climate side
you know one of the things that's been
constraining and i don't think folks
write about this enough is
the
incredible hollowing out of the u.s
government
as we came in
and one of the things that folks at epa
and other regulatory agencies have had
to do is build up that strength that
capacity to be able to do the analytical
work to underpin regulations to the
point earlier we've got to make sure
that these regulations are grounded in
the best science and the best data the
best engineering work um but if you look
at our record uh you know i just tick
through some of the sectors you look at
the industrial sector um we finalized
regulations that will take hundreds of
million metrics tons uh out of the air
in the form of hydrofluorocarbons uh
avoided
you look at the oil and gas sector
we proposed the most sweeping methane
action strategy and rules requirements
around reducing methane emissions and we
went and we galvanized the rest of the
world to come along with us over a
hundred countries joining that ambition
you look at the auto sector which is
going through transition we've sit we've
been at the table and this is because of
the leadership of the president and the
vice president we've been at the table
with the automakers with the
environmentalists with the engineers
with the scientists and with our
brothers and sisters in the uaw and we
forged historic standards that will
reach further than ever before on
electric vehicles and on fuel economy uh
so you just tick through it uh sector by
sector we've made
tremendous progress and the regulatory
muscle is not the only one that we're
leaning on just last week
the president signed an executive order
last week he signed an executive order
setting new goals for procurement how we
use our buying power as the largest
purchaser of goods and services in the
world how we use that to accelerate
progress in electric vehicles in clean
power and 24 7 clean power in the
building sector even in clean materials
like clean steel and clean cement so
i don't think there's uh any
any uh shot were not taken uh i think we
are excited to be able to lean in and do
it in a way that's grounded uh in uh the
best science grounded in the best
analysis uh and that's going to bring
folks along bring along uh uh uh the
good paying jobs that the president
talks about every time he talks about
the climate
on buildback crisis um uh there's
multiple reports that sandra mansion is
uh objecting to
including drilling bans off the atlantic
and pacific coast as well as gulf of
mexico uh how significant of a loss
would that be what is the white house
doing to keep those in the bill and just
separately
a ban on drilling in amwr is still in
the package what is the white house
doing to ensure that that stays in the
package
well let me talk a little bit about what
we've been doing um you know this is a
president that came in uh and
right over there
signed back the protections for bear's
ears an incredibly important national
monument and grand staircase escalante
he halted leasing in the arctic refuge
and in chaco canyon
important places to protect for
posterity
he set the first ever national
conservation goal
and is galvanizing folks across sectors
across states and local governments in
tackling the climate crisis in a way
that recognizes it's not just what we're
doing to nature it's that nature can be
our partner in taking on the challenges
that we face and look we've had
incredibly productive dialogues in the
context of this bill and and others on
how we take on the climate crisis in a
way that marshals the power of
nature-based solutions and the
bipartisan infrastructure law by the way
hopefully i get to come back for the 21
billion dollars we're going to spend to
remediate uh the places we've fouled and
that can now become hubs of economic
activity and hubs of climate solutions
based in nature uh that was in the
bipartisan infrastructure line brought
together democrats and republicans in
both chambers of the house passed
something historic so we're excited
about that work uh and and we're moving
forward it does seem like the drilling
bans are now not in buildback better so
i mean how significant of a loss would
that be and can you still achieve your
climatic goals if that is left out so i
think i'm going to let karine go into
the into the well into the into the into
the minutia of the negotiations um but
let me just say because i think it's
come up a few times jeff started it so
he gets uh he gets tagged with it um
you know
we've got an incredible crisis that
we're taking on in the form of climate
change the president
set an incredibly ambitious national
target 50 to 52 emissions reductions by
2030 he did that in april
and we have done everything we can to
pursue the multiple pathways that are
available to us in every sector there's
no silver bullet when it comes to the
climate crisis uh but there is a thing
as being too late there's a thing as not
being ambitious enough and we're trying
to make sure that we are as ambitious as
we can be leaning into every opportunity
we've got in front of us and i think
today is a great example of recognizing
the intersections of these policy areas
recognizing the opportunity that's
embedded in the crises that are in front
of our communities
and being as i think a president and
vice president model for all of us happy
excited warriors chasing after the prize
here which is to be partners to the
american people uh and oftentimes folks
who have been left behind uh and looked
over so we're we're grateful to be part
of that work awesome thank you so much
lean into the possibilities love that
okay
okay a couple things for everybody at
the top but first i want to welcome the
members of our domestic policy council
who are here i'm just i'm continuing a
tradition that jen started uh earlier
this week in welcoming some staff
members here and also the climate team
they do amazing work and we couldn't be
here without all of the policy you know
walks the walkiness that you guys do so
thank you so much and welcome
um okay a few things at the top i think
there is a yep there's a chart we know
we love charts here
today we received further evidence that
our jobs recovery is one of the
strongest ever
the average number of americans filing
for unemployment
over the last four weeks is now at its
lowest level since 1959
as you see uh 69 pardon me 69 giving
ourselves 10 extra years but i meant 69
here
we've added nearly 6 million jobs this
year the most any first year president
in history and the number of people
receiving unemployment benefits has
dropped from 18 million to 2 million
since president biden took office
thanks to the american rescue plan and
our successful vaccination program
americans are back at work at a
record-setting pace
and families have more money in their
pockets americans on average have about
a hundred dollars more in their pockets
each month than they did last year after
accounting for inflation
but even as
even as we built an a and historic jobs
and economy economic recovery we have
dealt with rising prices and supply
chain challenges because of the pandemic
along with every other developed economy
fighting that inflation and lowering
costs for the middle class is the
president's top priority while other
countries face similar challenges
america uniquely in the world is racing
ahead with more jobs more growth more
new small businesses applications and
more opportunities allowing us to tackle
rising prices from a strength of
position
president biden has taken strong
progressive measures to combat these
actions with a port action plan the
largest release from our strategic
strategic petroleum reserve ever and
actions to combat anti-competitive price
gouging including the industries that
that affect food prices and today the
administration builds upon the
president's port action plan and recent
investments in our nation's marine
highway system with new actions to
strengthen america's truck trucking
workforce another critical link in our
supply chain
so over 70 percent of american goods are
shipped by truck and in most communities
trucks are the only form of delivery the
truck action plan will cut red tape make
it easier for people to get commercial
licenses expanding trucking
apprenticeship
and launch outreach efforts to recruit
new drivers including by reaching out to
veterans who already have the skills and
experience to fill these jobs this is
the largest action the administration is
taking to address supply chain blockages
with the goal of reducing prices so this
is a big day
for the administration
lead pipes and taking on the supply
chain with the trucking our truck
announcement
yesterday the department of education
released new data showing that 99 of
students are enrolled in full-time
in-person learning this year the school
year the data shows that not only did
schools open their doors to offer
full-time in-person learning this year
but the but that nearly all students and
parents actually chose to come back as
well this is very good news and in
alignment with one of the president's
top priorities it's why he pushed so
hard to pass the american rescue plan
which is giving schools funding to
continue implementing mitigating
mitigation measures as well as help get
students back on track this week
secretary cardona also visited baton
rouge and highlighted how american
rescue plan funds can be used for
tutoring hiring additional educators and
putting in place other supports to help
students recover and accelerate their
learning
and last but not least today deputy
national security advisor for cyber and
neuberger and national cyber director
chris inglis put out a letter to
directly communicate with ceos and
business leaders around the country
about the specific steps they can
initiate now to reduce the risk for
their organizations during this time of
heightened risk and into the new year
some examples of these steps include
changing passwords and mandate
multi-factor authentication backing up
your data and ensuring you have an
incident response plan in place there is
not a specific threat we are tracking
but historically we have seen breaches
around national holidays because
criminals know that security operations
centers are often
short staffed delaying the discovery of
intrusions and with that i'll give it to
you go ahead thanks karine uh is there
any comment on the release of the us
missionaries who were held in haiti was
the us government involved in getting
them from
so
we welcome reports that they are free
and getting the care that they need
after their ordeal clearly uh we are
thankful for the fbi the state
department and haitian law enforcement
officials who have been working
tirelessly to get these missionaries
safely home
as jake sullivan said when this ordeal
began the president received daily
updates on this issue the us government
has been working tirelessly over the
past two months to get them released and
get them the medical care and support
they need after an ordeal like this
protecting the welfare of americans
overseas and freeing americans held
against their will is a top biden
administration priority for any
specifics on the details of this i would
refer you to the department of state and
then today the president had a
conversation with several senators about
voting rights can you um you know talk a
little bit about that the senators that
he was uh talking to and how did that
conversation uh come together in the
first place so initiated by the white
house or the senators uh so today the
president as you just mentioned darlene
and the vice president met virtually
with democratic senators to discuss
voting rights
the senators provided an update on their
progress
and the president and the vice president
reaffirmed the importance of acting to
ensure that every american can vote and
have that vote be counted the members
they spoke with include senator schumer
senator schumer kane king klobuchar
mansion merkley tester and warnock the
president has been getting regular
updates on this from his team who have
made who all of us have made voting
rights a priority
yesterday he was asked a question in
kentucky and he said that if we can get
congressional voting rights done we
should do it if we can't we've got to
keep going there's nothing domestically
more important than voting rights it's
the single biggest issue was he speaking
generally about voting rights in the
sense that if we can get it done we
should do it or was he trying to say
that bill back better should now take a
back seat and voting rights the senate
that's a joke
[Laughter]
so let me just let me just lay a couple
things out for you uh the president has
made clear that the system that
systematic effort to deny people the
right to vote in this country is just
plainly wrong
unconstitutional and goes against the
very foundation that our democracy
was built on president believes the
right to vote is the cornerstone of our
democracy and has repeatedly urged
congress to act to protect the right to
vote and access to voting he has
addressed this issue in front of
congress he has addressed this issue
privately with members of congress and
senators as i just read out
of both parties he's done this he has
addressed this issue with civil rights
leaders at the white house and so you
know protecting the cornerstone of our
democracy should not be a partisan issue
but sadly what we're seeing is that it
has this has been the case so in the
past voting right has been a bipartisan
issue so my question to republicans
republicans are how has this changed why
has that changed so as the president
said yesterday to your point there's
nothing more urgent nothing more urgent
than vote passing voting rights and
getting that done
anyone who knows this president has
followed this his his
career on voting rights and knows this
is belief is core to who he is and we'll
continue to work with congress to get
this done and he's going to continue to
focus on it and so will his team
thank you um earlier this week the white
house described talks between the
president and senator manchin as
constructive and productive uh but
sources on the hill say that these talks
have actually been going you know very
poorly and it does now appear that
zilbach better doesn't have a path
forward this year so i'm wondering how
now would you describe uh the
conversations between the two and what
again were those areas of productivity
earlier this week so as you all know you
know we don't go into specifics we have
a policy of not talking about uh private
conversations and even manchin said that
himself you know person-to-person uh
conversation should be kept private um
so the president discussions with
lawmakers outside of readouts that we
have uh usually we we keep that promise
so i don't have any more details to to
offer beyond what we've said this week
you know the president is is determined
to get this done as soon as possible uh
you know to cut we're talking about
cutting costs uh for american families
we're talking about child care elder
care
we're talking about prescription drugs
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
which is so critical and important to
american families and just to to
americans across the country
and also universal pre-k all these
things are critical and that's what the
president is going to continue to focus
on and i'm hoping you can clear
something up here when it comes to the
question of 2024 uh the vice president
did an interview with the wall street
journal and she was asked if she assumed
that bible would run again and she
didn't say yes she just said that the
two of them haven't talked about it of
course you all and the president himself
has said that he does plan to seek
re-election so
what's the disconnect here i i mean i
can't speak to a conversation that the
vice president and the president has i
could only say what and reiterate what
jen has said and what the president has
said himself that he is planning to run
for re-election in 2024. i i don't have
any more that but just be clear when the
president says he plans to run again he
means with harris on the ticket
yes he does
there's no change yes yes okay uh karine
the uh can you give us a sense of where
the white house sees build that better
right now
do you expect to get any more progress
before
the end of this year or
is it likely now from your perspective
as well to be done
uh in
2020 as you know we love process
questions here let's see
so you look there are a number of
conversations happening behind the
scenes and i'm just not going to to get
i'm not in a position to to to give you
an update or to get ahead of of that of
what the process is going to be here
today uh what what i can reiterate how
important getting buildback better done
this is a priority for the president to
lower cost again for americans that i
just listed out child care elder care
prescription drugs
universal pre-k all of these things are
highly critical to american families and
that's what they want us to see to see
us do is to deliver and that's all going
to be our focus and one more on comed
the variance is raging deaths and cases
are up in this country and worldwide
the president unveiled his winter plan a
few weeks ago
broadly given where the cases are right
now do you feel does the white house
feel that its strategy is working so
we know that the tools that we have in
place is indeed works right and the
president what he did with his winter
plan that he put out a couple of weeks
ago is just to build on that build on
what we know works uh so our commitment
um just to lay out a little bit here is
to sharing information uh transparently
and as expeditiously as as we can
we also want to make the most important
thing clear and we must all in this
moment of the pandemic we both know and
have the tools as i just mentioned we
need to protect us
different than any other points of this
pandemic if you think about where we
were a year ago
we had less than one percent of the
population that was fully vaccinated now
we have 71 percent of the american
public that's uh fully vaccinated so we
are in a different place than we were
before and that's because what we know
is working what we with the tools that
we have we know are working so the most
important important and encouraging news
we have is that vaccines in particular
boosters we know protect us and thanks
to the president they are widely
available so yesterday dr falchi told
the american public that the existing
vaccines are optimal for our protection
against omicron so we need to get
everyone who is vaccinated now boosted
we've made them readily available
they're free and through the winter plan
as i just mentioned we have aarp doing
extensive outreach to our most
vulnerable
pharmacies doing proactive outreach and
expanding availability and have a
continued ramp up
paid media campaign driving americans to
their boosters we also know it's
critical americans not lose sight of
masking indoors where cdc recommends
this we've we've been clear that we must
follow the simple measure we know helps
to stop the spread and and beyond
vaccine effectiveness we're looking at
transmittable severity we know vaccines
and importantly boosters are critical as
dr fauci also message so we also know
this is more transmittable variant the
omicron and so we have to do everything
that we can
to get people vaccinated quickly and get
boosted and also boosted as as quickly
as we can so
so we're just going to continue pushing
forward uh the plan the tools that work
uh to get to get americans vaccinated
and boosted
um
just back to bill back better for a
second some senators emerged from their
lunch today suggesting the president
himself would have a little more to say
about
the future of feel back better later
today is that something we should still
be anticipating so i don't have anything
to share with you clearly if the
president has more to say we will all
let you all know but i don't have
anything at this moment or you came out
here speaking of boosters um and it may
have
crossed paths with you guys coming out
here the cdc
vaccine advisors to the cdc apparently
voted unanimously to recommend people
seeking vaccines or boosters go with
pfizer or moderna instead of johnson
johnson
the cdc director will have to make a
decision ultimately and should be
announced later today i guess
i'm just curious at this point what
would be the message to somebody who has
a j j
shot and is it responsible for the
united states to continue distributing
that shot not only in this country but
around the world if the vaccine advisors
are saying so as you know asip is an
outside advisory panel so
the asic regular regularly meets to
discuss the vaccines uh and clinical
usage as dr linsky said yesterday so
it's not unusual this is regular
regularly happening whatever decision
they come to come to will go then to dr
wolinski and we
will follow
once we get that but what we know right
now and can focus on is that the
importance of getting vaccinated and
boosted as i just laid out we have three
effective vaccines available to people
widely around the country and right now
what we know it is critical to get
vaccinated and boosted to protect
yourself from omicron so that's what we
know at this moment is that we have
three that are effective if she were to
come back and say
and this is a hypothetical i'm going to
stress that yes
we do not like hypothetically
we know how
whether she could say we shouldn't be
giving up j j anymore and how quickly it
could be removed from the market
we don't i can't get ahead of what dr
valencia is going to say we follow the
science we you know we listen to the
public health experts that's our motto
here the north star if you will and i'm
going to leave it to dr wolinski
okay um just uh want to circle back to
russia have there been any updates in
terms of i know there's obviously
official
in moscow where things stand on the
talks any announcements about future
talks maybe coming in the days or weeks
yeah so um
we're constantly uh consulting closely
with our european allies and partners to
determine the best way to proceed with
the security talks that president biden
and president putin agreed to very
recently
today national security adviser sullivan
had a call with his b9 counterparts
yesterday he spoke with russian
presidential foreign policy adviser
today assistant secretary of state karen
donfried is is in brussels meeting with
nato allies to brief them on that
conversation and on her meetings in kiev
and moscow which she had this week our
focus continues to be diplomatic
progress and de-escalation that is the
most important thing here we believe
progress is possible on ending the
conflict in eastern ukraine through
implementation of the minx agreements in
support of normandy format so that is
our our focus right now
okay and then just one more uh circle to
build that better you know i know the
president's a veteran of these types of
things 36 years incentive vice president
does he view this as just kind of a step
in the process is it a setback what's
kind of his perspective on where things
stand right now in these talks yeah so i
just to step back for a second and uh
look at the big picture of what we've
been uh dealing here dealing with here
so this president and the congressional
leadership team working with two of the
are working with two of the narrowest
majorities possible has passed several
of the most impactful uh economic
legislation in american history he
turned around a failing covid response
and a sputtering economy and he's taking
strong action to address the financial
challenges that americans care about the
most his leadership and bills
and and those bills now resulted in
unprecedented economic recovery that is
the envy of the world historic job
growth the fastest
drop in unemployment in history
strengthened supply chains and boosted
competitiveness against china we
delivered because we stayed focused on
what the american people care about and
did the work that's exactly what's
happening here meanwhile republicans are
actively seeking to hurt the pandemic
response uh ex explicitly rooting for uh
information in pardon me
inflation uh to get worse and so there
are they're blocking uh what we're
trying to do for the american people
which is bringing down the cost and
doing the work on behalf of the american
people so of course any president wants
anything
pockets of families across this country
at a time when unfortunately it costs
a cost of the cost of some everyday
things have gone up
we we'd hope that everyone in this town
regardless of poverty would support it
the president was clear when he signed
the child tax credit
extension into law as part of the
american rescue plan he viewed it as a
vital tool to fighting child poverty and
helping family
families so the president believes the
child tax credit is highly effective
policy and needed no now more than ever
and that's why he included in the
buildback better plan so must it remain
in the buildback better plan because
there's some talks about it possibly
being moved and maybe not in a separate
plan if the mansion will not support it
well all i can tell you right now is if
we pull what we've been hearing and
people have been asking us would we
would what how would we support it being
in a standalone and the thing is the
reality is you need 60 votes in the
senate there are no there we do not have
60 votes in the senate uh to have uh to
do that as a standalone so we're going
to continue to make sure that we we work
we work with the senate uh to really get
bill back better done just really
quickly on voting rights i know you said
that there is nothing more urgent for
the president right now than voting
rights but it does seem like bill back
better all these other things have taken
a priority over voting rights like that
that there has not been movement and
there is a great deal of frustration
from you know activists voting rights
activists about that so i guess how do
you address that to say that it is the
most urgent thing but it does not seem
to be the top priority legislatively let
me just run through a little bit of what
we have done because i think that's
important i feel like sometimes that get
that gets lost as we're talking about
voting rights and it shouldn't because
the president has made this a priority
voting rights has made this a priority
throughout his career and practically on
day one so dozens of white house staff
work on this priority every day and it
is fundamental to upholding the rule of
law
you all heard the president speak about
this at length at the 10th anniversary
of mlk's memorial which is which was not
too long ago
decrying the big lie and making the case
for voting rights legislation here's
what we've also done because we are not
waiting for legislation we wanted to
make sure that we we moved forward very
quickly and got some of these things
done so the president's historic
executive order in march which he signed
on bloody sunday and which agencies have
now submitted actions plans for
leveraging the power of the
administration to protect the franchise
and make it easier to vote that's one
doj has been doubling their voting
rights staff at the civil rights
division as well as taking steps to
ensure compliance with voting rights
statutes launching a task force to
combat the increase of threats against
election officials and election workers
and issuing guidance on a variety of
issues pertaining to fair and secure
elections and the president appointed
the vice president at her request to
lead this administration wide effort
using the bully pulpit and convening
power to the white house
so the president believes the right to
vote is in critical it's crucial to the
health of our assistant of our system of
government so that's what we've been
doing so i don't want that to get lost
i'll get to you in a second
thanks green um
i i wanted to also follow on this
tax credit um issue with joe manchin i
remember
a couple months ago we were sitting on a
tarmac um delayed because the president
with much fanfare uh came out and
announced they had a framework that had
sort of signed off from senators um and
then this week we've learned that joe
manchin
has either asked for child tax credit to
come out or
sort of pitched a 10-year child tax
credit that would cost 1.4 if it's 1.75
trillion dollars so
um
based on that
has joe manchin sort of reneged on on a
commitment that he made to the president
when you guys made that announcement or
did you not actually have the
announcement in hand before we did that
look justin as i said we're i'm not
going to get into uh private
conversations uh certainly not going to
lay out what has been negotiated or not
negotiated i'll let the i'll let senator
manchin speak for himself on what he
wants included or not and where he sees
this and then uncovered in response to
jeff you said that the tools that we
have are working and that they take the
point that if you're fully vaccinated
and boosted the chance of severe arm
from covered to you your personal risk
is relatively low
but that doesn't describe a majority of
americans and just in the last two weeks
we've seen cases of 40
deaths of more than a third
and so i'm wondering in light of that
are you guys still categorically ruling
out
the possibility that we might see
lockdowns this winter uh especially
considering how
boosters have not kind of had the uptick
that we would need to see here
and
yeah are there going to be any
operational changes here at the white
house obviously that you know the
president um
79 years old he's been boosted but uh
the virus is swirling in a way that we
haven't seen probably in a year i look
as it relates to shutdowns which is what
i was trying to convey uh to jeff as he
asked me this question look you know
we've been very clear dr fauci has been
very clear
our public health experts have been very
clear we know what works and we're going
to continue to do what works which is
making sure that you know we do
everything we can to get folks
vaccinated we're at 71 of people being
fully vaccinated that's a huge
difference to where we were a year ago
as i just stated a year ago we were at
less than one percent we're at 83
percent more than 83 percent of people
who have at least one shot so we're
doing the work uh to get us there with
boosters about more than 50 million
people have gotten that booster shot
and the president laid out his winter
plan about two weeks ago to really talk
about those dozens
the 12 tools additional tools to build
on what's working to make sure that we
offer it uh we have that american public
feels like they have that access and
feel and feel comfortable in getting
that booster shot so it's important we
got to make sure that we take care of
our seniors our most vulnerable so that
is what we know we listen to the science
as i said that is the north star for us
we listen to health uh health health
officials and uh and so we're going to
continue doing what we know works and
continue to talk to the american public
about that
thanks green first a little before you
came out here uh report across why is
the administration suspending talks for
cash payments to the families of illegal
immigrants separated at the border if
the president has said you lost your
child it's gone you deserve some kind of
compensation no matter the circumstance
did he change his mind does he no longer
think that these people need
compensation so peter it's ongoing
litigation so i would refer you to the
doj i can't speak from from it from here
about it from here okay a question about
crime recently the mayor in san
francisco is now trying to add police
funding because when she pulled it to
reinvest in communities
crime went way up so would president
biden is the leader of the democratic
party advised democratic mayors not
to pull money from police budgets
uh so
i i can say this it is absolutely
unacceptable when grand
gun crimes are taking lives when
families don't feel safe going to the
park or their local schools when thieves
feel impunity and stealing from
retailers so we applaud uh the mayor
making sure that there is more police
presence uh in in the city to protect uh
americans and so if you're a mayor this
is what we say to local leaders if
you're a mayor or local leader there is
a crime problem in your community we
think you should step up and do
something about it uh just as many
mayors are already doing and we're and
we've made clear that we're going to
offer federal support to help you do
that and to keep communities safe as
just one example the department of
justice announced last month grants to
help put 50 more cops on the beat in san
francisco and funding for over 1 000
more community oriented policies
policies rolls nationwide the president
has proposed doubling that program so we
want to make sure that
that mayors and and local leaders do
indeed a step up and make sure that
they're protecting their community and
then just one more topic really quick
very important
okay just quickly why is president biden
telling people still that the vaccinated
cannot spread covet
can you can you say yeah in a local
interview on tuesday he said how about
making sure you're vaccinated so you do
not spread the disease to anybody else
the cdc says
people who get
vaccine breakthrough infections can be
contagious well i'll say this i
i didn't hear this interview so i would
have to see it in its full context what
i know and what the president believes
is that we have to listen to the science
uh we have to listen to our public
health officials and that's what the
president believes thank you
[Music]
we'll have more to share with with you
on that later but we know if we have to
go uh but and if you want you can come
and see me in the back and i can get you
more information thanks everybody thank
you
thank you
thanks everybody